bonjour à tout donc vous présenter
aujourd'hui un petit peu les et que la
physique en fait est au coeur de notre
vie et qu'en fait elle a contribué à
l'amélioration du confort de l'homme et
l'amélioration aussi de tous ces outils
qu'ils utilisent quotidiennement
partant du téléphone portable du réseau
électrique et de beaucoup d'autres
applications aussi donc la physique
n'est pas seulement une recherche des
lois de la matière mais bien sûr c'est
aussi une recherche des lois de la
nature
comprendre et pousser les limites de la
connaissance mais c'est aussi avoir un
petit peu une vue et des applications
pour l'homme qui seront justement très
utile et on voit en ce moment la
rapidité avec laquelle ces applications
sont en train de d'avancé alors je
commencerai un petit peu par
l'électricité justement comment
finalement cette l'électricité qui vient
du mot électrons lambres jeunes qui
avaient cette propriété d'attirer les
petits objets qui au départ on croyait
que c'était de la magie que c'était un
pouvoir divin
et puis il faut attendre justement la
loi de coulon vers le xviiie siècle pour
expliquer ce phénomène qui en fait
consiste en une interaction entre des
charges des particules chargées donc en
fait les particules l'achat de la
matière en en des propriétés qui est la
charge électrique donc être du type de
charges et donc c'est il faut attendre
vous avez vu vous voyez un petit peu con
mais on a attendu pour comprendre cette
électricité statique qui était à
l'époque objets d'amusement dans les
salons donc c'est un petit peu une
première entrée de la science mais
plus tard avec la pile volta nous allons
nous passons de l'électricité statique à
la pile et la pile c'est la création du
courant électrique
plus tard en 1830 c'est la découverte
voilà des phénomènes induction et on
voit un petit peu entre 1700 et 1800
cinquante sept grandes évolutions de la
compréhension des phénomènes liés à
l'électricité
on montre entre autres justement que
l'électricité le mutisme sont liés et
que la engendre l'autre d'où d'ailleurs
le mot électromagnétisme et c'est
maxwell en 1964 qui comprendra
finalement que ce phénomène est un seul
phénomène et que la lumière et les ondes
électromagnétiques sont produites
justement par un champs électriques et
magnétiques et nous allons voir que les
ondes électromagnétiques sont au coeur
de notre vie et on est inondés dont tu
alors ses ondes
en fait elles partent du domaine radio
qui sont des très basses fréquences de
grandes longueurs d'onde micro ondes
infrarouges lumière visible raviot les
rayons x de rayons gamma alors
l'approprier toutes saisons doubiste au
même problème lois de la physique
elle se propage tout à la main vitesse
que la vitesse de la lumière et dans
notre vie quotidienne
donc elles ont des applications très
variées
donc le courant qui circulent dans nos
maisons qui est le courant 50 hertz et
les basses fréquences
ensuite nous avons le courant les
fréquences radio puis l'autre fréquences
qui sont les fréquences utilisées pour
les téléphones portables
ensuite les micro ondes les micro-ondes
que nous utilisons pour chauffer la
nourriture puis l'infrarouge et le
domaine visible qui est la lumière qui
en fait le seul type d'ondés
électromagnétiques 100 pour lequel notre
et sensible parce que notre oeil est
capable de voir que les ont dans le
domaine visible
donc vous voyez que les le domaine
visible n'est qu'une petite fenêtre de
tout ce spectre électromagnétique
puis arrivent les le domaine de l'ultra
violet et les rayons gamma qui qui
constitue en fait les ondes électriques
les plus énergétiques qui sont très
nocifs pour l'homme
alors voyons un petit peu juste comme ça
au passage tous les appareils que nous
avons sont vont détecter ou à mettre des
ondes électromagnétiques donc nous avons
des antennes dans tous les appareils que
nous manipulons qui sont en fait des
objets très simple qui ont été conçus au
départ comme étant résume en terre et
qui sont maintenant de plus en plus
sophistiquées de plus en plus
miniaturisés et de plus en plus
performants alors d'autres d'autres
propriétés comme par exemple le radar
qui est tout simplement un système qui
va émettre une onde et romantique qui va
se rencontrer un obstacle et donc va
être réfléchie et le radar est donc
incapable de de prendre en compte cette
information est de détecter et de
position de déterminer la position de
l'obstacle
alors voyons un petit peu maintenant
justement le spectre électromagnétique
il nous permet de ces le messager de
l'univers dont qui nous permet de
comprendre l'univers qui nous entoure
donc les étoiles et les galaxies les
amas de galaxies tous ces objets
célestes
on en fait on les étudie à travers la
lumière qui nous envoie et cette lumière
là vous voyez elle elle balaye tout le
spectre électromagnétique pas seulement
le domaine visible et on peut voir par
exemple justement que le même objet n'a
pas du tout le même aspect si on le
regarde par exemple dans le domaine
radio ou dans le domaine visible donc
beaucoup d'informations sont tirés de
l'univers et beaucoup de questions sont
encore
sont encore sans réponse en particulier
la masse de l'univers
la masse de l'univers si on compare la
masse détecté la masse qu'on mesure où
qu'on détecte à partir de rayonnement
qu'on reçoit et les les conséquences ou
les prévisions quant tirs à partir de la
dynamique céleste à partir de la
relativité générale on se rend compte
qu'il est en contradiction et donc il y
a semble-t-il une masse invisible donc
une des questions de l'astrophysique
actuellement c'est oui cette masse est
ce qu'on n'est pas cap de la détecter
est ce qu'il existe vraiment et
peut-être que il faudrait encore de
nouvelles théories pour comprendre la
masse manquante dans l'univers alors
voyons un petit peu justement seul
heureux de l'atmosphère dans tout ça est
ce qu'on est capable d'observer de 2 est
ce qu'on reçoit à la surface de la terre
tout ce rayonnement non et heureusement
d'ailleurs parce que notre atmosphère
nous protège du rayonnement très
énergétiques qu'est le rayonnement gamma
et les rayons x et en fait c'est la
couche d'ozone justement on parlera
peut-être mon collègue cédric lucas donc
cette couche d'ozone nous protège de ce
réellement très énergétique parce
qu'elle absorbe ce rayonnement dans les
hautes couches de l'atmosphère donc est
justement un des risques pour l'humanité
c'est que suite à notre grande activité
humaine à l'échelle de la terre il y ait
une réduction de cette couche d'ozone
détérioration de cette couche d'ozone
d'ailleurs il a quelques trous par
exemple dans l'hémisphère sud voisine à
dieu dans le chili par exemple et donc
c'est grave pour l'humanité parce que là
effectivement sera ce rayonnement est
très nocif pour le corps humain et donc
donc vous voyez que finalement le notre
activité humaine a un impact sur
la protection re sur comment dire sur
les propriétés enfin sur la vie la vie
de l'homme et donc donc là on doit pas
quand même négligé sarr et on doit pour
le futur faire attention à préserver
l'environnement et même être prêt à
entreprendre justement anticiper sur ces
différentes conséquences qui pourraient
être je dirais pas irréversible mais
grave pour l'humanité
alors donc si on regarde un petit peu
finalement les fenêtres
électromagnétiques qui peuvent arriver à
la surface de la terre on a juste le
domaine radio et heureusement donc c'est
comme ça qu'on peut justement communiqué
d'une surface d'une partie à l'autre de
la planète et le domaine visible
alors comment on fait pour observer le
rayonnement électromagnétique qui ne
viennent dé des galaxies des étoiles et
c est bien fait on envoie des satellites
justement au dessus de la couche
d'atmosphère et c'est comme ça qu'on
arrive à couvrir tout le spectre
électromagnétique de rayons gamma
au rayon radio est donc cette recherche
nous permettront de mieux comprendre
l'univers de mieux comprendre l'origine
de l'univers le big bang et les premiers
instants de l'univers qu'ils ont c'est
en encore constitue une des questions
brûlantes de la physique de
l'astrophysique
alors je passerai maintenant un d'autres
aspects ce que la physique non seulement
consiste à chercher les limites de la
connaissance mais la physique a été au
service de l'homme et en particulier
pour la médecine la la radiographie aux
rayons x bien sûr c'est très commun mais
surtout il y à d'autres d'autres
utilisations comme l'imagerie par
résonance magnétique qui a trait qui a
été développée ces dernières années
je reparlerai un petit peu plus tard la
radiothérapie et récemment récemment la
nano technologie permet de développer
des nanoparticules qui vont nous
permettre de de faire un traitement des
cellules cancéreuses mais localement
donc en fait le principe est le suivant
c'est que ces nanoparticules ont une
fréquence propre et en fait on va aller
les excités à leur fréquence propre don
qui va se passer un phénomène qui
s'appelle résonance et ce phénomène de
résonance va chauffer localement
eva brûle brûle et si vous voulez en
quelque sorte détruire les atomes les
les cellules cancéreuses qui se trouve
dans une région bien déterminée donc
cette méthode de de traitement du cancer
et elle est moins invasive elle elle va
pas justement détruire tout le corps et
elle va se localiser sur les régions
malades
donc voila un petit peu un des objectifs
de la nanotechnologie aujourd'hui c'est
la physique au service de la médecine
alors je parlerai ensuite justement d un
service de la physique au service de
l'informatique est là depuis les années
70 en fait on à la visite permet de
déterminer les propriétés des matériaux
conducteurs isolant semi-conducteurs
semi métaux donc et en particulier les
semi-conducteurs en vue ont pris une
place très importante dans le domaine de
l'informatique en particulier le
silicium alors mais pas seulement les
silicium donc les semi conducteurs sont
utiles pour les jonctions pn les
jonctions sont les uns des éléments
essentiels des transistors et les
transistors nous permettent de
construire un microprocesseur
si on regarde un petit peu l'évolution
depuis les années soixante dix on a le
nombre de processeurs n'a pas arrêté
d'augmenter il a doublé tous les deux
ans dans un le nombre de transistors à
doubler tous les deux ans dans un
microprocesseur et ça c'est pourquoi
tout d'abord pour augmenter la capacité
de calcul
la rapidité est aussi la tendance vers
la miniaturisation donc ces deux effets
conjugués nous amène justement à la loi
de moore la loi de moore qu'est ce qui
vous montre un petit peu l'évolution du
nombre de transistors
par par microprocesseur et on voit cette
augmentation vertigineuse
alors maintenant on arrive justement aux
limites donc on est en train d'augmenter
ce nombre de transistors dom com et on
arrive un limite qui est la limite où on
va plus pouvoir entasser encore plus de
transistors et donc on est en train de
céder remporte que ces dernières années
on va arriver à la limite de ses
microprocesseurs et qu' il y à un
nouveau défi justement qui est à nous
c'est que le futur ça va être les
ordinateurs quantiques ou maintenant on
va avoir une autre conception de
l'ordinateur pourquoi parce que en fait
les électrons sont tellement proches les
uns des autres dans cette pro c'est dans
ce processus de miniaturisation que
finalement on va atteindre les limites
de la mécanique quantique dans les quais
dans laquelle on peut pas de façon
précise et est déterminé
donner à la fois les caractéristiques de
la position et de la vitesse de
l'électron par exemple et donc on est
obligé de passer à une autre théorie
plutôt probabiliste donc beaucoup de
physiciens sont en train de travailler
sur ce sujet qui est un sujet très
excitant est bon la phase vous voyez
dans le processus est à la recherche
fondamentale ensuite vous avez vous
allez avoir la phase de recherches et
développement puis la phase
d'industrialisation donc ce cheminement
est long et il est bien sûr ils
dépendent du génie des physiciens de
leur capacité d'innover donc je suis sûr
que certains d'entre vous contribuerez
comptes vont contribuer justement à
cette innovation est d'ailleurs les
boîtes de qui sont en train de
construire les microprocesseurs ont
beaucoup investi pour la miniaturisation
de des microprocesseurs mais je pense
qu'on est en train d'arriver vers une
limite donc on doit aller vers autre
chose hélas les capacités d'innovation
sont très importantes et elles sont très
souhaitée alors d'autres défis de
l'avenir justement sont l'énergie
aujourd'hui l'énergie pose un grand
problème pour l'homme parce que notre
vie a évolué nous sommes en train de
consommer plus d'énergie parce que nous
avons plus de besoins plus de commodité
+2 et jusqu'à présent l'essentiel de
l'énergie utilisée c'est une énergie
fossile le pétrole le gaz naturel le
charbon mon l'uranium aussi mais c'est
pas notre c'est pas notre source
d'énergie favori alors il faut penser à
des alternatives d'accord et donc là la
solution c'est les énergies
renouvelables d'accord alors la question
des énergies renouvelables est une
question qui est encore un sujet de
grande actualité de grandes recherches
et là aussi il faut avoir il faut faire
conjuguer les efforts des physiciens des
industriels dans le domaine de la
recherche et développement
pourquoi pour optimiser
ces systèmes donc vous avez le solaire
thermique dans lequel en fait en
concentrent l'énergie solaire en un
point qui va permettre ensuite de
transformer cette énergie en énergie
thermique
vous avez aussi les l'énergie éolienne
l'énergie hydraulique l'énergie
géothermique biomasse donc toutes ces
sources d'énergie sont encore à
améliorer en termes d'efficacité en
termes de coûts alors je parlerai par
exemple de l'énergie photovoltaïque
l'énergie solaire photovoltaïque en quoi
elle consiste vous avez le rayonnement
solaire qui est qui est là qui est tout
le temps présent et en fait on va
transformer ce rayonnement
électromagnétique du soleil en un
courant électrique
maintenant toute la question c'est de
savoir comment va améliorer la
performance parce que ces systèmes n'ont
pas encore un rendement assez
satisfaisant et leur coût est élevé donc
d'autres donc les recherches se
poursuivent mais ya pas seulement la
question de de l'énergie de la notion de
d'extraction d'amélioration des
performances et et des rendements mais
il ya aussi toute une autre
problématique qui ceux qui se posent à
nous c'est comment distribuer l'énergie
comment la stocker comment réduire les
pertes et en particulier on voit que par
exemple on pourrait utiliser les
surfaces énorme de de désert pour des
panneaux photovoltaïques à volonté mais
la question c'est après comment
transporter l'énergie alors une des
possibilités
justement c'est pour éviter les pertes
vous savez que les pertes sont entre 5
et 10% de pertes
ça dépend des distances plus les
distances sont grandes et plus les
personnes importantes donc l'une des
possibilités et les physiciens pensent à
cette possibilité
c'est par exemple d'utiliser des
supraconducteurs qui n'ont pas de perte
justement par effet joule vous avez dû
voir l'effet joule la résistance la
puissance dissipée par réjouissait
ricard et donc ces matériaux les
supraconducteurs n'ont pas n'ont pas
d'effets joule et donc c'est très
intéressant donc on peut réduire ses
pertes
seulement cette propriété
n'existe pas à la température ambiante
il faut refroidir le matériau pour
qu'ils deviennent supraconducteurs donc
donc les recherches actuellement sont
très intenses pour comprendre les
mécanismes dans ces matériaux et pour
comprendre le l'origine de les
mécanismes responsables de
supraconductivité voilà une petite vidéo
juste pour vous montrer ses propriétés
magiques des supraconducteurs
ce sont des matériaux qui qui en fait
non seulement en résistivité nul mais
ont une propriété d'expulsion du champ
magnétique donc pas ça la diapo suivante
donc ces matériaux expulse ligne de
chant et donc ils ont une propriété qui
qui peut engendrer par exemple un
phénomène de lévitation donc un
phénomène de lévitation qui est utilisée
justement au japon pour les trains donc
les train à lévitation
on passe à la diapo suivante alors les
autres perspectives de la physique sont
la recherche de nouveaux matériaux
alors les nouveaux matériaux par exemple
les matériaux tels que le graphène les
matériaux composites
alors peut-être on revient très
rapidement supraconducteurs donc là je
montrais tout âge je parlais tout à
l'heure d'été train à lévitation
ensuite les autres applications des
supraconducteurs s'il vous plaît le
chant l'utilisation des supraconducteurs
dans l'imagerie par résonance magnétique
parce que justement on a besoin d'un
champ magnétique stable et ça c'est
possible avec un supraconducteur c'est
pour ça que dans les installations irm
il fait un peu froid parce qu'on a
besoin de refroidir ces matériaux
supraconducteurs c'est matériaux
supraconducteurs sont aussi utilisés
pour dans une grande installation c'est
une des plus grandes expériences la
physique enterré alizés c'est dernières
années c'est le lard de l'aja tony
collider dans ce style et se situe à la
frontière franco suisse est un grand
accélérateur de particules dans lequel
on a justement
détecté pour la première fois le boson
de x qui ad'ailleurs fait l'objet d'un
prix nobel et ce boson de higgs est une
inde et maillon qui restait à prouver
dans le modèle standard qui est le
modèle qui régit toute la physique des
particules et qui est aussi capable de
de donner un petit peu l'ensemble de la
théorie de la physique
donc c'était un peu le maillon manquant
donc c'est une expérience qui constitue
un peu le couronnement de plusieurs
années de recherche dans le domaine de
la physique des particules
je finirai par donc les ordinateurs
quantiques et donc cette possibilité qui
peut être fait avec des supraconducteurs
ensuite aussi ces nouveaux matériaux
par exemple les composites vous savez
dans les dessins animés en voit on voit
des voitures qui se qui se tamponnent
qui se déforment et puis tout de suite
elles retrouvent leur forme initiale et
ben bientôt ça sera de la réalité parce
que ces matériaux composites
ils ont trait résistif ils sont très
légers et sont capables de retrouver
leur poser leurs leur forme si vous
voulez chauffer un petit peu les
chauffer avec les conditions nécessaires
donc ce sont des matériaux de l'avenir
qui seront utilisés pour l'automobile
pour l'aéronautique et aussi pour les
loisirs pour les commodités
encore un dernier un dernier slide sur
un matériau magique le graphène qui a
aussi fait l'objet d'un prix nobel il a
quelques années et qui pendent on pense
que ce matériau d'un matériau magique
qui est capable de
il ya les électrons n'ont presque pas ne
ressentent pas leur masse du tout donc
ils sont très légers ils ont très forte
mobilité dans le matériau le matériau
très résistant et on pense qu'il va
ouvrir la voie vers la nanoélectronique
voilà c'était un petit peu pour vous
montrer un les perspectives de la
physique qui sont encore très grande et
j'espère que vous allez contribuer à
l'innovation dans la physique et à
révéler les nouveaux secrets de que
qu'elle nous cache
merci